bonjour et bienvenue dans cette vidéo
très particulière puisque aujourd'hui on
avait quelque chose d'assez fou on va
faire une partie de loups garous dans un
décor de dengue et des costumes de
taille puisque ont fait cette partie
dans l'univers de la série the witcher
qui va sortir sur netflix jeu pas vous
mentir je vais incarner le personnage
principal jeu est plutôt beau gosse j'ai
très hâte de voir comment la partie va
se dérouler il va avoir des trahisons me
sauve de jowhar des coups durs des coups
bas nord du sale et du drôle de ça c'est
prêt non personne n'est prêt
je me mets en slope tu vois je peux
filmer j'ai aucun problème avec la
nudité est bien bonjour les amis je vais
interpréter avec brio le personnage de
jasses kg et arrêtent à je ne supporte
pas vraiment je ne supporte pas qu'on me
touche pendant que je parle j'ai hâte de
mettre ma perruque en fait monsieur venu
pour toi c'est que de gauche avait tancé
matin mon nom et wiegel forte les
pouvoirs incroyables phénoméne on
regarde
je suis j'ai mis des clauses incarnerait
le personnage de istres and this aya est
une grande sorcière regarde forme
allemand là je veux faire du grisouille
et sur ta caméra
moi je vais interpréter saga sourit je
suis sur scène avant 50 ans je vois ce
que tu avances mais jay karnes syrie
quéral ses paroles je sais pas je te
fais les sourcils un bon vouloir
eh bien écoutez je suis gêné faire je
suis sorcière surpuissante on dirait pas
comme ça moi je suis un censeur
voilà c'est mon métier de 10 et un tuba
magie ya du boulot
voilà on fait rentrer là tu nas gens
voient les devis ils sont validés
j'arrive sur le terrain je bute le
monstre voilà une petite particularité
dans cette partie c'est qu'on a un
maître du jeu tu vas pas de trop nous
faire peur non plus hein non non non non
mais le monde est fragile mais j'ai
sorti mon fils fragilité h et un peu
fragile monde d'accord je pense qu'il
faut qu'on prenne un peu de plaisir
aussi mais qu'en même temps il faut être
ferme avec les gens j'ai l'impression
des plus fermes occupées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après vous
donc si un prêt et mettront les tirs
kébé métro
elle sut pas déçu ali héros prenez place
à vos pupitre respectifs situés bien
volontiers héros de ce monde je réclame
votre attention je suis le maître des
âmes et c'est moi qui vous ai tous
convoqués ici
si je vous ai fait traverser le
continent s'est pour une raison bien
précise
voilà des semaines ceux de monstres cie
of des vies sont en jeu
chaude et conscience pardon je rigole
quand je suis stressée je disais donc
voilà des semaines que de monstre sème
la terreur dans la région plusieurs
meurtres ont déjà été commis sans que
personne ne puisse mettre fin à leurs
agissements
vous avez donc été appelés ici sous les
toits du château de caïx moraine le
sanctuaire des sorceleur un lieu dédié à
l'extinction de tous les monstres
j'ai tous réunis pour accomplir une
mission commune basée sous le signe de
la confiance retrouvée et terrasses et
ses monstres avant de débuter votre
aventure
je vous invite à boire chacun une potion
qui vous donnera un pouvoir spécifique
et vous aidera dans votre quête
il a besoin les alcoolisées ou non je
comprends pas je vous laisse choisir et
de l'ess le destin vous a plu et
simplicité
cette boisson sera la mienne je crois
que le destin a décidé pour vous je vais
maintenant vous décrire les pouvoirs qui
vous ont été attribués par le hasard
tout d'abord l'esprit embrouillé heures
qui permet au héros qui possède ce
pouvoir de changer de place avec deux
autres héros ensuite le troisième oeil
qui permet au héros qui possède ce
pouvoir de découvrir le pouvoir du héros
de son choix
tu es la guérison qui permet au héros de
ressusciter il a été tué par les
monstres au de ressusciter le héros tués
par les montres cette nuit-là et enfin
l'âme du diable qui permet au héros qui
possède ce pouvoir d'éliminer le héros
de son choix
je vous invite maintenant à boire vos
potions chose qui ait pas trop de temps
mais attention vous devez savoir que
vous ne pourrez utiliser vos pouvoirs
qu'une seule fois
buvez
[Musique]
des ondes maléfiques envahissent la
pièce les monstres sont parmi nous
derrière le visage de votre voisin votre
voisine peut se cacher un monstre ils
ont dû échanger les potions pour prendre
possession de vos corps soyez prudents
la nuit va tomber et demain dès les
premières lueurs du soleil nous pourrons
démarrer enfin de tradition
tout le monde pour tous parce que des
ondes négatives s'élèvent les monstres
sont parmi nous ils vont de nouveau
faire une victime je le sens laura
maléfique des monstres a disparue mais
je sens qu'ils ont laissé des traces sur
leur passage si l'un des héros veut
utiliser son pouvoir
il lève la main maintenant les rayons du
soleil réapparaissent à nouveau sur le
royaume
je suis au regret de vous annoncer que
les monstres ont de nouveau agi cette
nuit est-ce qu'on se méfie à ces deux
villes de force
je ne sais pas mais lui en revanche le
sait pas assez mais fils et les monstres
l'ont tuée cette nuit
avant de quitter ville de force
peux-tu nous révéler son identité
twitchell racing n'est pas john rachid
qui suit l'esprit embrouillé heures cet
état d'esprit en brouillard il nous
quitte maintenant les meilleurs partent
en premier on va manger jeu très énervé
parce que j'ai je voulais attendre
du coup j'ai pas pu utiliser mon espions
bruire je me suis fait des directs et je
suis très très déçu
afin de venger votre compagnon je vais
vous laisser débattre et vous me désigne
aurait ensuite votre suspect que cette
position défensive jacquier c'est dans
cette direction
quant aux monstres ou se réveiller j'ai
entendu je préfère alors ça je valide
valeurs vertes quand tu dors tu bouges
geralt on a déjà dormi plusieurs fois
ensemble je valide
ah bon vous avez dormi ensemble et j'ai
entendu du qi moi c'était non mais j'ai
entendu du cuir je suis habillé de cuir
way n'étaient pas censés bouger gasquet
peut-être je suis musicien vous le savez
très bien à l'oreille absolue et j'ai
entendu du bruit
voilà
j'étais un peu de cuir alors je ne sens
pas le préciser yens fr il ne peut pas
le faire j'ai entendu du bruit par là et
j'aurais tendance à penser que c'était
la droite c'est elle qui te pied c'est
sûr j'ai skié parce qu'en général la
tendance à désigner les gens proches
parce qu'après c'est vous pouvez voter
contre moi ya pas de problème les
parents ont d'ailleurs le regretter
parce que je ne suis pas un bon et je
jure sur la tête de ma mère
cela s'est passé plus en jeu là je n'ai
pas envie de partir maintenant
moi je suis un dur à cuire et j'ai bien
entendu que ça venait de là je vais
maintenant vous demander vos votes
basque et les incas story je suis l'ami
tiens je maintiens j'ai skié série jeudi
j'ai skié sur les amis vous pouvez
encore changer la donne ces regards mais
voilà allez y allait faire cuire man
merci gfr istres est désolé mais je suis
un match très puissant jet ski et saia
je me range à la majorité gasquet a mis
mes amis j'étais effectivement très déçu
de votre comportement
allez mon [ __ ] éliminé à cinq voix
contre deux oui mais c'est bon c'est pas
la peine de préciser
j'étais la guérison ce qu'il ya tu veux
maintenant nous quitter je veux pas me
guérir de maintenant vous allez utiliser
ton pouvoir romain stratégie de jeu est
simple c'est de ne pas pleurer en
quittant le jeu si vite
voilà c'est eux c'est tout chers amis
oui une fois de plus le sang a coulé sur
le royaume mais la lune se lève de
nouveau il faut prendre du repos et
repartir sur de bonnes bases
je ne dormais que d'un oeil nous les
amis
ni faire comme la nuit dernière les
forces négatives se réveille c'est l'un
des héros ici présent utiliser son
pouvoir
il lève la main rappelant
c'est marrant il n'y a pas de bruit de
cuillères qu'on n'appelle pas les
monstres
obligé de dormir ça vient c'est discret
tout ça héros du continent réveillez
vous ben je me suis réveillé dans le lit
de quelqu'un d'autre
encore une fois les monstres en frapper
tac a souri a été retrouvé assassiné
donc ça veut dire que c'était cyprien
qui était qui a été visé à cas sourit
pas en paix mais avant révèle nous ton
pouvoir et l âme du diable non visibles
tracasseries et tu peux maintenant me
quitter ce qu'on verra ça casse ça passe
ou ça casse tout donc j'avais la
possibilité de de tuer une personne
pendant la nuit j'ai réussi à passer le
premier tour et ensuite je me suis fait
éliminer pendant la deuxième mi mars
et c'est assez cocasse et je me suis tu
es mon même attention il n'y a pas eu
qu'une victime cette nuit dirais que
même les plus doux d'entre vous inspire
aucune pitié à ces monstres istres aide
au nom a été retrouvée défiguré mais le
beau visage
c'était l'esprit embrouillé heures merci
streit je vous dis depuis le début le
cul tu est la personne la plus sucrée
que porte cette ce continent merci tu es
un héros sucré mais jamais ma sucre ans
je me suis dit je vais attiré les
foudres des monstres pour intervertir
veux ma place avec eux et je me sentais
pas ses clients lui
ça sent le monde et j'ai changé avec lui
j'ai fait un tour je sais pas ce que
j'ai fait mais j'ai mal calculé et du
coup jours mais après je continuerai à
venir sur la chaîne de cyprien
tranquille comme et sans rancune
déjà il faut comprendre le truc c'est
que si près et hélas ouais je sais tu
m'as pas le mec qui a accusé son pouvoir
sait pas qui a été désigné donc il a
mélangé au hasard à du gros de ses
listes red café le mélange ses soins
vrai franchement j'ai passé nul ton truc
est passé sur ces noms meyer a passé des
moments où c'était côté la reine des
neiges déjà dit c'est sur ces nappes non
mais franchement c'est pas ben c'est pas
moi donc en fait on fait quoi on va dire
on est venu de passer au vote tueries et
me faire mais bon allez c'est bon la vie
vers lui le cuir c'est les deux monstres
et sur garonne
si sa gamme hygiène fr évidemment les
deux monstres sont là ils réfèrent a été
éliminé par tes camarades avant nous
quittait révèle montons pouvoir
troisième faire tu peux nous quitter
merci assure qu à travers balacé mort m
bah oui tu es mort ce que tu m'as mais
c'est terminé entre eux c'est que du
mensonge
voilà c'est tout et puis moi je constate
qu'en fait dans ma vie j'ai aucun
charisme que les gens ne m'écoute pas
parce que pourquoi on veut c'est une
tragédie et ne reste qu'un héros passe à
deux monstres maintenant veuillez me
révéler vos identités de traite
il n'y a pas de traîtresse quand il n'ya
pas de promesses j'étais le troisième à
quatre le mettre dans le cul
non
les manchots l'ont emporté tous nos
héros sont tombés et sans enjeu pour
combattre les monstres je vois déjà les
rivières du royaume se teindre de rouge
je refuse d'abandonner je suis sûr que
les choses peuvent encore bouger que
nous pourrons refaire appel aux
sorceleur pour combattre ces monstres
sanguinaires tout peut encore changer
[Musique]
ailleurs ça fait bizarre de devoir
sacrifier ses amis jamais eu autant de
douleur dans mon coeur et j'ai été hyper
blessé je suis absolument désolé d'avoir
tué en a un
chacun de mes partenaires de jeu mais je
pense qu'on a joué un peu stratégique il
faut savoir qu'avec audrey on a une
grande complicité aussi de monstres tu
m'a brisé chasse et du coup ça c'était
c'était un peu dur je suis désolé ah non
non non ça c'est une connerie ça on en a
déjà discuté non c'est une connerie
c'est sympa de riz après ce que je sais
c'est vrai donc voilà après tout cela
n'est qu'un jeu un bon netflix en chine
et ça passera exactement et pardon oui
mes chers amis tu peux dire oui mes
chers collègues
mon cher collègue du travail alors que
j'étais un prix bien et fait maintenant
je veux dire vous venez finalement je ne
m'excuse d'avoir été menée par quoi il
ne vient pas comme il est
j'ai pu me défaire d'une équipe
la personne qui a tout fait capoter
n'ont jamais vu le sourire vous vous en
foutez là planté pourquoi parce que
j'avais désigné sept personnes pour
mourir et il n'y a de la place déliot
regardez je suis désolé que d'avoir
trahi ses amis d'avoir type et mes amis
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce
petit mieux si je vous ai tous
coussinets la connaît bien on a du mal
le mensonge dans vos veines
après voilà pourquoi acheter sa place
j'ai passé vraiment super en prochain
volet
[Musique]
c'est une belle image dauphin
m